والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان
لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
ك رياض الصالحين من كلام سيد المرسلين
الحافظ النووي
وعن زر بن حبيش
زر بن حبيش
مخضرم
ايش يعني مخضرم؟
مخضرم بمعنى انه ادرك الجاهليه ولم يلقى
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم هذا يقال له
مخضرا لان حد الصحابي
من ادرك النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم والتقى
به مؤمنا به ومات على ذلك فاذا اختل شيء
من هذه الشروط
لم تنعقد له الصحبه فزر بن حبيش قيل انه
ادرك عليا وعمر
وادرك الجاهليه كما نقل
الذهبي في الكاشف الا انه لم يلقى النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم فهو مخضرم او من
التابعين
زر بن حبيش زر بن حبيش
مخضم
صلى الله عليه وسلم
120 years
الله تعالى
الكوفه قال اتيت صفوان بن عس
صفوان بن عسال رضي الله عنه كبين هي كوفي
رضي الله عنه غزى مع النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم عشره غزوه رضي الله عنه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
رضي الله عنه
صفوان بن عسال
معاويه
خلافه
ابو بكر عمر علي عثمان
رضي الله عنه زر بن حبيش
ask صفوان بن عسال
وضو
قال جئت اتيت صفوان بن عسال رضي الله عنه
اساله عن المسح على الخفين فقال ما جاء بك
يا زرو فقلت ابتغاء
فقال ان الملائكه تضع اجنحتها لطالب العلم
رضا بما يطلب
do their wings out of
the student of
due to their respect
فقلت انه قد حك حك في صدري حك حك في صدري
يعني ضايقني شيء انبني في صدري عنده شيء
من الاشتباه في الحكم انه قد حك في صدري
المسح على الخفين بعد الغائط والبول
وكنت امرا من اصحاب النبي صلى
عليه وسلم فجئت اسالك هل سمعته يذكر في
ذلك شيئا
said
unclear
with regards to the rulings of wiping
over my footwear after relieving myself
within or defecating and you are a man
who
صلى الله عليه وسلم
قال نعم كان يامرنا اذا كنا سفرا او
مسافرين الا ننزع خفافنا
ثلاثه ايام وليالي ولياليهن
الا من جنابه
لكن من غائط وبول ونوم
ifavate
impurity
rather we
من غائط وبول ونidate
things
are command
by him to our footwear with notice the
wordwear
الخف
lether
translation
is not it takes the place of shoes a
person would notar a
that's not something that would be done
a person would either wear
صلى الله عليه وسلم
سلمه
ابن
[Silence]
‏serund
because
ackn
alone
‏in shoes
are not standone
wear them with shoes and so oftentimes
people they lether socks
what comes to their mind is the leather
socks that are in the islamic stores
those soft you know sheep skin or
socks they put on and some people go out
of their way to bu these
خف
مذاهب وائمه المذاهب
‏tak place
you
up standot
right
lether
is a standalone footwear that you can
walk up to a m in right alone these are
all things that none of these leather
socks fit
‏isen
lether
would place
and prop
sometimes would
and companions andallyes
would socks made
الخف
الخفعل
more
life
and things wip in time is prohibition of
wiping over a person socks no whether
cotton socks
وضو من غائط وبول ونصف
عال
‏urination andleep areief
invidators of
because invid
by sleep
willing
الله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا